Well.
Well go to your mom's house.
Yeah.
Okay.
Shadow
[inaudible].
Oh my God. Yeah. This is the
classic. I'll leave that.
We submit some really good
songs to Holy Shit, man.
Whore respecting his pronouns
now. It sounds like that
is a, he always is amazing.
It reminds me of, I got stung.
I used to dance to massage.
Really? Yeah, that was
great. That was fantastic.
Did that in the car just jam out? Yeah,
I get down and stuff like that. Bad.
Does fat finger in my ass.
Who that by? Brian Marshall. Instrumental.
Thank you Brian. The bet. The bubble.
This fat. That is fat. Um,
what do you got? Jeans. Oh,
let me go first. Okay, I'll start off.
September 27th. Hold on.
You got me by surprise.
You never let me go first.
Come on me by somebody that
had the copy up on my phone.
One of the suggestions that came in
for one of your cities. Yeah, I do.
In that acid plus,
um,
in my asshole lips. Sorry. This is for
any APP. Let's start with Seattle. Uh,
September 27th, Seattle. I got
skeet and hole. Watch me come
or fuck my stomach,
come,
come and me club in fuck my stoma
watch become. Wow. And it's a lot.
It's number 27, Seattle,
Tacoma, comedy clubs.
September 28 Portland's your God damn.
Reading dates of September 28,
Portland Shortland,
Oregon at helium comedy club.
October 4th, Portland.
Portland. Yeah. October 4th.
Dallas. Tay Hos what's Dallas? Dallas.
October 5th Poussin de Texas,
the super group juice in
Texas, the secret group.
October 23rd, Indianapolis,
uh,
in the acid fits Indian assholes.
It in my asshole lips in that ass and Puss
and Maurice Company clubs.
Thanks Karl.
Thanks Kyle for those submissions.
And then October 24th, uh, since,
since he shat on me.
That's fantastic.
Sit on my fatty. Sit on your daddy
or save some for daddy though. Hi.
Oh, you're great. Go Bananas.
And then a December 9th and 10th,
Washington DC at the DCM. Prov all
tickets are@thousandorchange.com. Yeah.
Don't you hate when people say Warshington
yeah. Thousand ranch. Come see me guys.
Well, I got it cut low to date. Uh,
starting August 4th,
I'm in Timonium just outside of Baltimore
and Magoo because the real name yeah.
Puts Timonium.
Timonium sounds like perennials.
Perennial.
I'm in premium Tillich.
My to like Mike Micah come to like
my com Timonium I'm into like my come
Maryland. Uh, then come on my bus, Ohio.
That's August 11th and 13th.
Then the big announcement,
the reason I had to move a few things,
we haven't set it on the show.
I'm doing the odd ball tour.
Oh,
a lot of great comics on the lineup.
Uh,
Sebastian Maniscalco I know
a Gaffigan's doing a date.
I think Brian Regan's doing a date.
Uh,
John Oliver's doing one of
the dates and then Malanie um,
a bunch of people are on them.
Even they even created a space
for board Chrysler to come on.
You're kidding. More Chrysler. Yup.
Fattest working comedian and yeah.
How are they going to find a jet for him
to fit on? Oh, no, no, no. Yeah. Yes.
To Dry.
That's why I was only doing it for you
because they can't all link someone local.
Yeah. Yeah. Um, but uh, yeah, Eliza,
a couple. It's a lot of people.
So Eliza Schlesinger,
she's doing it and it all starts August
25th in West Palm Beach at the vodka
amphitheater and we go all over man.
Of course I'm only doing short sets.
That's the way this stuff works.
Explain to people. Yeah. The way,
the way that this works is that there's
like a big name every night. Um, like a,
you know, a bigger comic, big name
comic. I mean some nights, like I said,
it's bigger isn't it? No, it's a,
you know, a bigger ticket drop. So some
nights it's like Sebastian, like I said,
Brian Regan,
Dane Cook's doing a few go to oddball
and you could check out all the links are
on my site.
So you can see that.
And the way it works is that all the
comics that are kind of not as known,
we do 15 minutes sets,
usually something like that.
And then the big, there's an
intermission, it's a long show.
So there's intermission. A guy does
like 30 or 40. They take a break,
you come back the uh,
the rest of us do like the 15 minute sets.
And then, um, then the, the big name,
we'll close out, do a 40 minutes
fun show.
I mean Joey Diaz is doing a few.
Yeah, and we're doing, like I said, West
Palm, Tampa, Atlanta, Chicago, Toronto,
Hartford, all over the place.
Man. When that finishes,
October 2nd, I go to Charlotte,
North Carolina on the October 14th,
and then I go to man Fran Disco.
And that's more names for that.
Well that came in.
I wanted to to be pat and Rhode Island
submitted Manhattan Man Hands Fist,
whole
blue bands piss whole boob as Piss Pole,
blue badge.
And this whole fem men Lik
pole and 10 man squished pole.
Wow. And it also said,
what about Kim An asshole?
Oh No, that's the best
one. Really killed it came.
So those are all all day.
It's go to Tom cigarette.com.
Click on the show's page and
get your tickets now jeans,
you want to get us started bits. He's
licking blue bands leg. I think he's hot.
Dog flavored. That's why. Oh my
God, you look a little hot doggy.
Your skin tone today.
Schnitzels obsessed is looking blue
band right now. It's pretty funny.
What kind of bird seed did you eat this
morning? In that hand? Just a, you know,
classic, classic mix. That's probably why
ready for this. All right, let's go.
Oh, there we go. So gross or
you feel already pretty good?
What were you in for your
tonsils? No, a colonoscopy.
Yep.
Yup.
Loving to them?
No.
Well we'll go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Okay.
Uh, what happened to poor
Ari? You had a colonoscopy.
We were texting about it the other day.
MMM.
He's awfully young for those. Don't you
start at like 50? I don't know. Yeah,
he had, he has like asshole problems
I think though, you know. Right.
He always had a constipation. We've
talked about using Emirates, you know,
you were his ass hole would swell up.
Does he have like a prolapsed?
It looks like it looks really
bad. It's really bad. Or
Buddy by then. Then he said,
um, he said they just, you know,
you have so much air trapped in you after
that because it's just like after they
poke around in there to see yeah. He
goes, it feels like you're going to shit,
but it's just fart. Interesting.
And he said, I mean,
you just have to sit there and Fart for,
for what? Oh, it's our baby. Oh my God.
Do we have another dog?
Sounded like a dog. Um, yeah.
I mean, he's in the crate. Right? You left
him? Yeah, he's totally fine. He's graded.
All right. Um, but yeah. Are you
just said that these parts were nice.
Trust
you feel already pretty good. Good.
What were you in for your tonsils? No,
a colonoscopy.
It's quite a farming.
Do you ever, do you have
a game tonight? Yeah.
I may not make that connection.
This is all one, one sitting,
one hour foods. It's just gas.
Three more farts.
Changes waves like mushrooms.
Yeah,
he is. Isn't he so bald? Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, by the way, this is a firm,
I think opie radio ope, they sent people
to videotape. Sorry. After that, you know.
Oh, to get those farts. Oh, okay. Yeah.
MMM,
yeah.
Are already saying that he,
but I think you should everything
out before the colonoscopies.
No more in you fast for the entire
day. We do on this pretty soon. Yeah.
I'm supposed to do this. I
have to look forward to, yeah,
but I feel like you're always doing this
anyways. Oh fart like that regularly.
Come on like that all the time. You
sit around and you heard it last night.
Even though I'm a little congested.
You farted a lot and I smelled
it through my whole time.
There wasn't last night, those
daytime? No, it was during the day.
It was after I got off the flight. I had
like some, some pretty Raunchy farts,
but that was like no sleep coffee,
you know?
Okay. That was pretty gross. All right,
so wait, when are you going to do this?
Um, I'm scheduled do it the 16th. I might
not do it anymore. I was thinking about,
I'm sorry. Why? Um, I just don't
think I need to do it. Why?
Because I don't think I have
anything to worry about. Sure.
Okay. I'm serious. No,
I know you are. That's, see this is the
problem is you are a serious, but then,
then you shit your brains out
every, every day. Every week. Go to,
I don't shut my brain shit all the time.
You need to get to the bottom of this
Mr. Out of my butthole. Yeah. No,
I think you should stick to
it. All right. All right.
Maybe I will. Maybe I will. I
haven't decided yet. I might
cancel. Please tell him.
I think I might cancel.
Nice version.
That's a whole new level of what do
you think she'll do your mom's house
Christmas album.
I really hope she,
she will kill our baby.
We uh,
we would love to have her a part of it.
Like Hitler Baby Danny.
Will you do the Hitler baby for the
your mom's house Christmas album?
It's really cool.
I think she would do it.
I think she might think we have to have
maybe a couple adults signatures on that.
A contractor,
a couple of guardians need to sign off on.
Well Danny and a few other voices
in her head to get on board.
Isn't the band you'll
going to shit in the album.
Catchy Hitler
oven tonight
certainly is critical.
The talent's there. It just needs
guidance. You think it's a good producer?
Well, Quincy Jones, her
and Dj dad mouth together.
Oh, check off my Christmas. I
heard the same thing you heard.
Oh my God. Oh, by the way, I
should point out to our listeners.
Um, they can't see me right now. To those
of you that don't know where on Youtube,
we are always on youtube. Every
episode. I'm dressed very nicely today.
I walked in the room and then blue van
and you were like, Hey, now you look nice.
And then I was like, oh, I'm out of clean
clothes. That's always the way it goes.
Right? Like the dirty or your
clothes, the nicer you dress.
There's a lot of layering of posters.
Interesting choices.
That messy right there.
That's what I see. I'm sorry.
It looks like Lionel Messi.
I don't know who that is.
You don't know who the fucking most
famous soccer player in the world.
Isn't that okay?
That's what I see.
I see a sweet little argent time.
Boy Jonas brother could be,
but I have my eyes on foodborne football.
She's a soccer fan,
I think d well she's an inhaler fan.
Argentina. Hello? We just tied
it all together. It's true.
That's how she discovered.
Interesting.
Can you like football?
I had the song you like
called it for Jesus' birthday.
Are you a massive fan?
Their dire then
maze by it? I really can't. I can't
joke about it yet. I'm still processing.
It's a lot. What I just
saw, it is quite a bit. Um,
he's pretty bold to put himself
farting on the inner webs,
but he was always like that. Right? Like
he always put Ari's asshole and his Dick.
Everybody pulled his dick out.
He did it at the Irvine proud
when they banned him for a while.
They just temporarily though.
Just never, I remember I did,
I've told this story before. I,
we're talking like a few years in.
I didn't really know. I knew who he was.
It's kind of intimidated by how like,
you know, dark and like his personality
was, you know, he was a Weirdo.
Ari and I was doing some west side show
and one of these little rooms with like
13 people and Mike Black was onstage.
And then Ari walked into the
room as Mike was onstage with a,
is that your phone? No.
No. And he walked to Ari,
walked on stage with his, uh,
with a tee shirt, but no pants,
no underwear. So just naked from
the waist down. Oh, your phone?
I don't think it is. Of course it is
right there. That's not it. It's too,
it's too far away. It's not too
far. Mine's normally down here.
I hear it.
It's gone now though. You have
to put it like on the floor. Oh,
here's the Ra right here. I texted
him. Shut up. What does he say? I said,
how are your results? Because
we didn't get to talk about
the results. He said, um,
you know, they don't know. It doesn't look
like there's anything. Oh, good. Yeah.
Those assholes. Good. Yeah.
Um, great news. Let's see.
Should we try calling him? Yeah. Why not?
Maybe I'll just see if he wants
to talk for a second. Yeah,
I like to hear more about those farts.
I'm going to call you right now.
MMM.
I think our audience needs to know too.
Yeah. And what's your IBS situation?
Mine. Yeah. I currently I'm
in, I'm doing real well.
That's why I don't feel like going.
Interesting. Why do you think that is?
Just eating healthier. That's why
I think it's just like food based.
You cleaned up your diet is what you're
saying and now you're not browning as
much. Yeah. Huh. That's interesting.
I know.
Okay.
How's yours? Because you have
some smelly rounds too, you know,
I wouldn't mind doing a wide on
smoothie work lately. A lot of um,
smoothies and that,
that's been helping me cleaning up.
Well it will be out of the
country for sure. I'll be back.
Oh my God. An asshole. He
just called. He just called me
man
friends of the worst.
I know.
Oh he wrote I'll get off with your mom.
[inaudible] asshole. Okay.
We try it again cause he showed us, he
is so weird about his phone. You know,
he has a flip phone. Right? You know
that about him had, I do know that. Yeah.
Why does need one
great,
hello? Hey. Hello.
Hey, you're on a recorded line. Okay.
Do you remember recording line? Yeah.
You're on a recorded line because we were,
we were just playing clips
of you on our podcast.
We were playing clips of you farting
and I was talking about how um,
hi Ari. There's Christina.
She's a high. Um,
but like can you take us
through the process? A little
bit of a, the colonoscopy?
Yeah. Okay, sure. So do
you get there or not all?
Let's back up. Let's back up. Yeah. The
whole day. But what are you getting here?
August 16th. Unless I cancel.
You're not going to cancer. God,
I'm always careful.
Don't cancel it cause I just don't feel
like I need it anyways. So go ahead.
Tell us about like the prep.
Oh,
okay.
So two days before or more you
got other stuff by rite aid.
You got to pick up this stuff.
Mira lax.
And let me see what else, if I still
have the effect that makes you sure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Don't, don't collapse.
And you got up to the double whammy.
Going back to one of
those is powerful enough.
So does that give you like PR
like powerful diarrhea or what?
It makes it just turned everything in
your, in your bowels into just water.
Ooh.
No,
didn't take a lot of the beer.
And then you like push it,
you know liquid shit? Yeah.
It's just that all day.
You can't eat anything that
day light you can't eat.
Then the midnight the night before.
Okay.
And then no solid foods
the whole day before.
And then he saw the light.
So to this point,
so the light and then
the whole day before,
that's fine with me. Okay.
You're a nibbler. Yeah,
I'm like a fucking bird, so yeah,
that's fine. And then wait, so wait,
one more thing. Can I ask you what
prompted you to want to do this?
I didn't ask you why.
Oh well what I shit I bleed a lot.
Oh No.
Is it red blood or dark blood?
Yeah. What color was it? Red Blood.
So the doctors haven't bride.
Okay. Getting metamucil button.
Let him do some things
like an old person thing,
but it's not like pools of blood. Right.
Cause this is your last phone call ever.
If it is,
it's not pulling the blood.
But although when I was in some hotel
somewhere I notice like drops of blood
from the bathroom,
the toilet to the sag.
Oh, all right. That's, that's a scary man.
How, how long has it been that way?
A couple of years. You know, Ari,
Jesus,
you're dropping the drip.
The dress wasn't only like a few months.
So we're doing it. We're
doing biopsies though. Right?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. All right.
Wait, what book? The biopsy?
Like they're, they're testing like,
uh, you know, um, from within.
You like your tissue tissue.
Yep. What did you want to look at it
when they want to do is just look at it,
get a good look,
and then they found one polyp.
So we're going to buy off the that.
Okay, look, that didn't look like guy.
We got to do a Kickstarter
already. All right. So, um,
oh dude. Okay. So halfway through the
day, if we split that mix, half a bottle,
half that mirror Lex bottle.
Yeah,
like a 400 milligrams until like
two different 32 updater. Right.
I'm drinking every 30 minutes.
So you start,
then 30 minutes later you take another
quarter of it and then 30 minutes later
get another quarter. Yeah, like you're
an hour and that's when you're like,
oh my God,
I hope that
square hawala home. But like 30 minutes.
Wow. I meant just opened
up. Just a dam just opened.
So you go in there and you're
completely empty. Right? When you go in,
you're totally done.
You can drink liquids they
before so that could come out.
The liquid keeps coming out and keep
dragging away. Any like any retina,
anything have left in your,
in your bile.
Keep shedding and shedding
and shedding and shedding.
So why were you so much? That's
after the colonoscopy though. Why?
I don't understand. Because there's
air being pumped into you. Oh, I see.
Rdo, they, Greg, you go into a
hospital gown and then they, they,
they put you in the room,
they turn you over on their
side, they give you the, the,
they put you out through your wrist
or something at the back of your hand.
I'm happy to, she called it when
they put you out, they put you out.
Yeah, they should. You don't want to
be in the one would be there for it.
So yeah, I did not know that. And I mean,
it was, it, was it like a turn on at all?
Like were you aroused at all?
Oh, I had a normal Boehner had,
wasn't like out of the ordinary.
Right. And that's all it
was. And it was one of the,
if it's something that Michael Jackson,
the good stuff.
Yeah. It, so when you come to,
you're just like, oh, we're like,
we're done. And then, and
then you're just full of air
30 to 40 minutes later. I
was like, Oh shit. Because I
didn't take it. It's all day.
The day before I had been shitting, I'd
be like, I don't have to sell, you know?
Yeah. So I'm like, no, I really got to
ship. It's not shit. It's just a hair.
And how long? Cause those
parts were awesome. How long
does those farts last for?
About two hours.
Wow.
Down though. Like really force it
out. I felt like it was Shitty,
but I looked at it a
toilet and it was nothing.
Oh Wow.
You're going to have to come with me
to this thing and bring the camera and
stuff.
Okay.
Yeah, for sure. It should do that.
Um, so wow. Well, I hope you're okay. Hey,
where did you have any dates this weekend?
Where are you?
Where are you going to be next?
I'm going to be an, um, I'm
going to be in or whatever.
I'm going to be in Montreal this weekend,
but then I want to Edinburgh
for the whole month.
Oh God. You're crazy for
doing that. Oh my God.
Yeah.
And then Scandinavia.
Nice. All right buddy. And we'll, you're
traveling the world. You're living it up.
We hope you were assholes. Okay. And
it's great and it gets such clear
pictures of the inside of your rectum.
Really Nice frame those.
Yeah, I'd like to see that
like a tunnel. You know, doctors who
when he goes through the tunnel in time,
it looks like that.
Good. I'm glad you're
assholes. A beautiful tunnel.
I can't wait to hear more.
I'll let you know how mind goes.
Yeah, I can't wait for you to do.
It will be a will be fun buddy.
Yeah, I can't wait. All right
buddy. I'll talk to you later.
Right?
Very
good luck. Wow. That's what you have to
look forward to. I'm stoked. I Dunno.
I might cancel.
So anyways,
do you now, do you see red in the bowl
too when you go potty? No. No, no.
It's where do you think
you have hemorrhoids?
Um, no, I don't think I have.
I mean I don't have hemorrhoids
problem. It doesn't hurt. No.
Okay, well that's good. All right,
that sounds like that could be a problem
when he's got going on. I think so.
Dripping blood was that.
It's,
if it's bright blood that's supposed
to be better than dark blood,
they say cause it's like star
last phone call for second.
Poor Ari Aries. Guys, pray for
Ari's butthole. Pray for it,
send him butthole wishes and
compliment them on those farts.
Hence,
by the way,
a bunch of people told me they were doing
my line to like their girlfriends and
stuff. Want to hear a cool fart and
they're going want to hear a funny fart.
That's how you say it wrong.
It's want to hear a cool fart.
And then when
they like turn Fart,
sometimes people don't say yes
so that you still wait a beat.
But it's always you want to hear a cool
fart and then for our end it's just for
the women listening. You
can say no, you can say no.
I say no almost all the time. I want to
hear a cool far now. That's how you it.
That's actually how it goes in
the house. Yeah. Yeah. Cool.
You know I really appreciate your fan
next to the bed that you man, turn on.
I hate your fan so much cause it makes
me feel like one of those tower tower
fans feel feverish and sick when I
sleep with a cold air blowing on me all
night. I angle it so it doesn't go on.
It still trickles down. Someone, man,
it doesn't make you feel sick or weird
or weird. Like I have a fever or
something, but if you feel cool,
hate it. I like it. Men Do
that and we have this thing.
I know my dad has slept with
a fan so gross like our baby.
Um,
my wife is convinced it was cold even
though even when it's 106 outside.
Yeah.
So the air conditioning,
which I would have down to
like 66 is that like 75 so,
yeah. I need the fan. He's a baby
though. He's, he's, they need,
they need one more layer
than you do. He's fine. Okay.
No he is fine cause I keep it
nice and warm in the house.
Every time I pick him up
from a nap or something,
it's just like heat just coming
off of his body. Yes, I do.
I think you should drop it another degree
or two. Seriously. All right. All right.
We'll do it tonight in the 60s but
I think you sent me three is fine.
I usually do 73 chocolate.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
All right
baby.
Let's talk about the fact that
I'm wearing a Danny shirt,
even though it almost all went to shit.
You're going to talk about that
on the air. Should I not? I mean,
unless you want to her Danny's
feelings. No, I don't want to have days.
You can't do that. Okay. He
basically just did. Long story short,
there was a miscommunication on the order.
Yeah.
You're going to get mad at Danny about
it. He said he's trying to fix it. Yeah.
I mean we, we in a shame,
the guy was, it was an honest
mistake. I think jeans, he's,
it's a language barrier thing.
He speaks English. Yeah.
But not perfect. It's a second
language for poor Danny. Yeah.
What's his real name?
I mean,
as good as the real Eric and I,
his name,
big words.
Um, his real name. I don't know where
you go actually. I deal with Alex.
Oh, so it's Alex's fault. Yeah,
but he speaks fluent English. Well,
it's fine. We're all good. We're all good.
You're right. I shouldn't try to make it.
I'm not trying to, I'm just going to
tell the story, you know, and I know,
but yeah.
Fed Ju Ju yeah.
Can we talk about our Sushi experience,
please? Okay, yeah, go ahead. Well,
we went to a new place
in our new neighborhood.
It's supposed to be like a really nice,
and it is a really nice place in the,
the fish was amazed,
like it was so good.
Yeah. It's, um, it's also like
very popular. This is one of the,
uh, I would say it's on lists, you
know, it's like on the foodie lists.
Write it up.
Yeah.
Which is why we were so
excited to go in and try it.
And we got a babysitter and all that stuff
and we went in and we did all Mcausey,
which is where the chef brings you
what he select. So we're like, great,
let's keep a common bro.
Like, and we should point out
that when we do usually go to Sushi,
we never do.
I'm a Casa because, you know, we know
what we like. Is that what I said?
I think that's what you said. Oh
my gosh. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Um,
we always know what we like and we
go, no, do you know, we'll do this,
we'll do this or, but this time we handed
it over, we go, do you guys do it? Yeah.
Yeah.
Well what happened was everything
was great. It was great. Amazing.
But they parceled it out
like two bites at a time.
They're like, here's two more bites. And
you're like, I'm fucking, let's eat man.
When are we going to eat?
And it would be like,
they were like, okay,
so you're going to get
all these things right.
So the first thing that
comes out as a plate,
we'd get a plate and it has two pieces of
fish on it. Delicious. So eat two bites.
Yeah. And you're like, great. And it
kind of sits like five minutes. Yeah.
Take it back. A new
plate too and too, God,
bye bite. Yeah. And then
these are a few more minutes.
Next play.
I was like four pieces.
Oh my God.
I'm infuriated.
And you got even the bigger,
even me as a Nibbler, I even,
I was hungry as a leveler.
Yeah. Yeah. And you got the,
the extra helping of it,
even dude.
And it was not enough
food. It's so, it was
clearly not enough. So when it was done,
I was like, hey, we need that menu. Yeah.
And they came back with it and they're
like, oh, well what do you need?
And I was like, a bunch,
a bunch more Sushi.
And then there was a table
next to us of this big, uh,
big, like Ozzy broad. And then her, um,
Japanese friends, Japanese friends, and
they're like, oh, isn't it great here?
I was like, yeah, it is. It's really
good. But you know, it's just not enough.
And then pork or goes, uh,
uh, uh, you don't think so,
right? Clearly thought so too. Yeah.
She's like, she's like, I think it's an a,
and I go look fatty. You're not fooling
anybody. You're, you're on my team. Right.
We both know this is not enough food.
You're not satisfied.
Don't act like you're satisfied.
Because she started to try to
like make it seem like, oh,
you don't think it's enough food.
I think it's plenty of food. Right.
It was like you're way over to bills.
There's no way you think
this is hungry as shit too.
She looks hungry at all hours of the day,
but the only person that looks satisfied
was her Japanese friend who's used to
probably eating that way and was like,
oh,
everything's pretty looked like she was
came out of an internment camp though.
Right. She's just like,
oh, we get our ration.
Right.
Yeah.
That's how I felt like they were throwing
a scraps and I had to eat it so fast
to get to know him the next day.
Just scrap was going to come.
Sushi wise I do.
My whole thing is just keep it coming.
Yeah. We order like a
trough. I need, I need,
I need them to just keep
dropping the plates, you know,
so that the table is just covered in
snow and then we just eat our way through
it and then we,
we waste because we can't even finish it.
That's when I'm happiest. Yeah.
A few pieces left and they go,
you want that and you can, I can't,
but the roles are the ones that I've,
I don't feel bad wasting roles. Yeah.
You don't want to waste the fish.
Yeah. I will go back to that place and
now we know the rule. We go absolutely.
Alica yes. And we go, do you
have a pen and paper? Because
you're going to need it.
Yeah.
Can I tell you what? I don't either. I
like Amaa Ebi. That sweet shrimp. Yeah.
But I liked him to fry the heads.
Don't do then they didn't do,
it's a weird thing.
That was very upsetting because I like
those fried fish heads. Yeah. I know.
Anyway, that, oh gee man.
Yeah, I'm Asian. I know. Uh,
but that was so far. I know. I've
never, I've never eaten somewhere.
And then Anne, and I mean this in all
seriousness, how do the full meal,
and then I was ready to go to in
and out. You were right. I was like,
let's go to the fucking Internet.
But we didn't, but we didn't. Yeah.
Well, pat on the back of that.
Yeah, I was. I really wanted
to, but I didn't. I know,
cause I knew that somewhere that
actually said it like four or five times.
I know I'm serious,
but that's how normal people eat is
they just eat one meal even though it's
parceled out, like you know you're in a
refugee camp. Yeah. No, no, no, no. Yup,
Yup, Yup, Yup, Yup, Yup, Yup. What do
you think your dad would have done there?
Oh my God. Well first of all, you
Sushi a buddy.
We went out with your dad for dinner
so that we had dinner with your folks.
Just the four of us,
two nights in a row,
everybody left after Ellis is baptism
and your parents stayed behind for a
couple of days and we had them over at
the house one night and the next night we
went out.
And what I noticed was your dad,
there's a few topics your dad
loves to. Favorite ones, murder,
killing and death. Actually three
favorites. Yeah. Killing death.
Murder. Yeah. It was pretty intense.
He talks about death the first night.
Well he goes, yeah, what was the
first night that was, but I'm on his,
his brother passed,
right.
Brother dying and details and like I a,
I went to the funeral home and like
picking out the casket and all of that.
My mom was like, come on like weird.
Like this is a nice meal about like,
all right. Then the next night he goes,
uh, what kind of gun are you going to get?
Ellis? And I go, he goes like for
his first gun. And then I got,
uh, I don't know, he was
probably 22 or something. I
go, yeah, you don't step it up,
you know, and then get them like, I dunno,
maybe a glock at some point and then, uh,
you know, 45 I get what I really want to
get them as a 50 caliber. It was like,
ah, and it like prompted something
in him. He goes, Vietnam,
we had these 50 cows too,
too heavy to carry.
She put him in the back of like a,
I don't know,
some type of a truck or something. One
day, like sky coming out over the field.
And you just kind of launched these fee.
I was like, Oh man, like he just gets,
he gets lost in this story.
And then something did it.
Like somebody cut them off.
Like my mom said, oh we've got to
go do this. And I was like, Hey,
you didn't finish that 50 caliber
story. And he was like, Huh?
I go the story about the 50 caliber, the
guys on the field. He's like, Oh yeah.
And I go, so what happens if you
hit him with it? He goes, oh,
you hit him in the show where
they die. Oh my God. Like
I still want like
the full story. That's another phone
call we should make and be like,
what's up with the physical it? Well,
and then it was a nice treat, a dinner.
We went to the final dinner,
the final dinner and you know,
we had pictures from the baptism
and it was beautiful and we,
we had this wonderful week, actually,
your whole family was great. You know,
my family. And, and then
he starts talking about
hospital deaths,
malpractice suits,
and all these horrific stories.
And they're all about like pregnant women
giving birth. I'm like, could you not?
Yeah. And then he goes to put acid on
a woman's vagina by mistake. I'm like,
yeah. And then he's like,
guy brought her daughter in and then my
mom was like, and what happened? She died
anyways.
How are you going to bite that kind bite
them that buddy like right from like
the death to like, what's
that? Is that good? Yeah. Uh,
I'd have loves talking about
that course we don't want. And
that's where you get it from. That's
your love of murder and stuff. Yeah,
that makes sense.
You're becoming your dad.
Yeah.
You're red dead. Hope he
answers. Please answer.
Are you asking about the Vietnam story?
Want to hear about the 50
caliber cause he didn't,
he didn't really finish the story.
Oh yeah.
Answers. Oh No. Bummer. Okay.
By the way,
I just need to sit down with you
and do it. It's been forwarded.
It's going to be an audio only episode.
Yeah,
but we have a full top dog
Charlie episode. DEPA right.
We're going to release it like a
regular episode. We'll talk before it.
It will only be audio cause this
doesn't make sense to like, yeah,
I have video of us just introducing it,
you know? Yeah. Or so that'll hopefully,
maybe I will try to do that for next
week or so. Okay. Um, yeah. So yeah,
he does love death.
A lot of death. Chad. That's on
his mind a lot, Huh? Yeah. Yeah.
It's really killing, killing, killing
cat and he drinks. It's so funny.
He was over here. They came from
the airport and I was like top dog.
Do you want to go back to the hotel and
change into something more comfortable?
He's like, I am comfortable. Always.
Always wasn't Khakis but down shirt.
Yeah.
Tie loafers, loafers. You
want to get some control?
I am comfortable buddy.
It sounds funny.
If that's what he wears
it on a Sunday afternoon.
You know what I love about your dad is um,
anything could be going on and
he doesn't give a fuck. Like,
he'll still just sit on
the couch and watch CNN,
even though there's a house full of people
and dogs running around and like any
kind of event, if he hasn't feel like
paying attention, he doesn't. Yeah,
I really respect that.
Yeah. And his whole thing too. If you
go like, what's the why? You know,
what are you, why aren't you like
over here? He's like, I'm bored.
Which is true. Yeah. I
agree. I get bored too. Yeah.
I'm going to start doing that from now
on. Just pulling the top dog. Yeah.
I just want to watch Netflix right now.
I want to fucking talk to you guys. Yeah.
And you go,
I'm going to do that.
You don't want to talk to
you go. You don't wanna talk
to so and so. And he'll go,
they bore me straight up.
We'll just tell you that right
person bores me. Yeah.
He keeps the 100 genes.
Do you want me to play this
song you say? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Um,
so as we all know,
there's a problem with people
sharing too much on social media.
And finally somebody wrote a song
about it and this is it right here.
Um,
I could love this.
I mean they really wrote a
song. Yeah, it's a good song.
Your Business.
Facebook,
there's a oversharing problem for sure.
Talked about it for a long time.
Many years we've discussed this problem.
Yes.
And a shout out to the s CG church
version of Qbo business off of Facebook.
I love it. Yeah, it's, yeah.
You don't need to share
everything. That's interesting.
There's really no shame left
in our society now. I mean,
everything is on the table all the time.
It's so crazy.
How are we going to
teach our kid about that?
You have to tell him not to send Dick
pics to people. That's a big thing now,
but imagine doing it. But I may
have done it if I had, well,
if I had a healthier hog on me,
I would have.
Here's the thing about photographs is
that you can't really tell scale of decks,
but if I had a real hammer on me,
there's no way you could keep keep it off.
You know,
you couldn't have convinced me to not
send it if I was like really equipped.
There's no way you could been like,
now do you understand?
It's only the shame of like somebody
seeing this petite little lights that I,
uh, I wouldn't, wouldn't send it so silly.
It's not a petite light switch babe.
Yeah, it is. It's not,
it looks like, it's like,
it's a little noisy.
It's like,
you know how when people get a hair on
their tongue and then they go and they
pull it off?
That's like my whole deck
was that I was like, I got the fuck. Am I
talking? Yeah, that's my Dick. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't think so.
Oh,
gross is my vagina. Now that I've had a
child, like how disappointing is it now?
That's great. It totally different.
I feel like it's totally different.
It's all blown out and no,
no,
I got ma meat sandwich. Yeah.
Loose meat sandwich. Yeah. No,
it's great.
It's great.
Well then your tiny painter and my loose
meat fits together. Well, you know,
that's how it goes together.
You would have sent your Dick Pics
to checks if you had the technology?
Oh my God, Dude. No, I had, uh,
all joking of size aside, I,
I have a, um, you know, a shame,
a nude shame. Maybe it was all the
Catholic upbringing. I wouldn't have,
I don't think I would have. Interesting.
I would never do that. I wouldn't know.
But I would, I think in terms of also
just blackmail, you know, like I said,
in my mind,
I wouldn't ever do that to somebody,
but I don't trust that somebody
wouldn't do that to me. Oh, right.
So you're saying,
yeah,
I feel that there's enough fear in me
that somebody would use that against me.
Yeah. They would scare me into not
sending it. But that's the thing.
If you don't put your
face, thank you, Betsy.
If you don't put your face in the
picture, then who cares? That's true.
I think that's the one, the
one way you have to do it.
I don't know. Yeah, I dunno.
Blue Banner of this generation.
Your friends are sending their Dick
pics everywhere. Did you ever send it?
Uh, I've never sent one. I have
had friends that sent it. Yeah,
I have the diverse, uh, so whenever
requests for you to send one,
like they go send me a dick pic? No.
No. Hmm. Have you ever seen like,
has anyone ever been put on blast so to
speak and then you saw their dick pics
and they didn't want you to
actually found out that
one of my best friends,
I went to a comedy show with uh,
one of my friends,
girlfriends and uh,
found out during the show,
the comedian asked if anyone had sent
like how to dig book sent to them and uh,
my friend's girlfriend like rose her
hand or raise your hand, raise your hand.
And uh,
it turned out that she was talking
about my friend and I found out at that
showed that my friend sent her a dick pic.
Hmm. I'm a little confused. I
didn't follow that and say that.
I just pretended like I did.
Yeah.
Well I found out during your show that
my buddy sent his current girlfriend
addiction.
Okay. Yes. Now. All right.
My last girlfriend. Yeah. No.
Was it like how he quartered her? Uh,
it was in the very early stages. Okay.
And had been going out for a
very long time at that point.
From what I understand, a lot of
women don't care about the Dick Pic.
I personally, I've seen, you know, what
you see all the time on social media.
Don't send me a dick pic in bias.
Yeah. Black people are like,
don't send me a dick pic.
Yeah.
So I think women get bombarded with Dick
Pics and they'd probably just trashed
them. Oh my God. I don't
think it's a thrill.
It's only maybe something to get really
into it. You definitely know sending it,
there's something
intriguing about the person,
but if you're just getting
unsolicited Dick Pics, I'm
sure you're just like, okay,
I am, I don't get sent. Never
got careful what you say,
please don't send me your deck pegs.
I really don't want them. Yeah. Uh,
but I feel like it's a particular type
of lady. Maybe you get, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Not In the married 40
year old kinds. You never know.
You never know. That's where it had two
girls send their snatches, their snapchat.
I think it's far less. I mean,
I'm sure that that happens,
but you don't really see, I mean I've,
I haven't seen any of my friends by,
I was like, stop with the pussy
pierced. Yeah, yeah. No, no,
I don't see that. Um, I don't
know. You see nudes? I Dunno.
I've had friends be like, oh, I'm this
girl that I'm seeing just sent me this.
But it's usually not like my leg
open. It's like a girl, you know?
But it's not just her snatch
isn't it? It's not just, no, no.
It's not like here's this
pussy for no, no, no. Yeah,
because women don't, we don't,
I don't think that way.
I think dudes are like,
you're in my dick because the other
guys that's enticing to gay men,
but not women to be a gay guy. Oh,
I know. And just be like, look,
it was cock this guy just,
I mean,
when Grindr happened, do you think the
gay community, just as your backflip,
like this is what the movement's about.
This is what we've been wanting to do.
I mean it started in the gay community
and then came, what's that shit? Tinder,
but it started as grinder was first. For
sure. You could just be like, who's in?
Who wants to fuck in my neighborhood?
Who was five miles from here or two
miles at once to blow me? Oh, that guy.
Yeah.
I mean like for the casual,
I got to get this load out.
That's is the most magical because he
used to just have to go down to the park
and stand in a particular area.
Right foot,
three times restroom stall
and just see what happens.
I know now it's like, yeah, those guys
get to go like, here's what I look like.
And you know how judgmental too. It's
like, it's like, look at me, I'm yoked.
Oh my God, you better be looking
like this too. Oh my God.
Then you'll find that like
your equal and you're like,
you can blow me so much pressure to
be a gay man. I don't think I can.
Thank God. Lesbian seemed to be a bit
more forgiving. If I ever, I could not,
I could not hang. No. Well,
you'd have to be a bear. I could,
hey in my lane,
but I couldn't hang with like,
you know the guys pretend if you age,
like you can't be over 30 and the gay
community as being a straight woman,
you see so many,
especially in La,
older gay guys that look like older
straight women as far as the other crazy
face backs and the lip and you're
like, dude, you look insane.
But it's because of that pressure probably
the more so than anything pressure on
yourself. Right? So to maintain the
look. But you see that a lot in la,
like old, older gay guys with
ridiculous plastic sir. Look, amaze.
No. Who looked, who looked
like it? They went too far.
I would say in south beach
it's even worse. You're right.
Go down to Miami and everybody that
roller blades by everybody that roller
blades by, they have calf
implants, ass implants,
the cheek and then everybody
looks so fucking weird.
I was in south when I was in south beach.
Everyone was on the beach and I saw
somebody vomit and I go, what happened?
They go,
I just looked at your body.
You and I so disappointed. We used to
go down to Miami. We were like the,
you know the Canadian pigs.
Oh look,
the Midwestern couples slobs.
Are
you from Indiana or so? Yeah.
And then now you see like so tan.
So lean. Yeah. Girls are
topless wearing thongs that are,
that are like sheer, like
it's see through thongs. Yeah,
and they have just perfect bodies.
The dudes are super yolked jogging
on the beach. It's Puerto Rican guys.
What their gold chains jogging.
I remember every morning that heat,
the sweltering heat, it's 102
out there. It's just to show off.
Your body plays all day every day.
Remember, if you can't get laid here,
you can't get lazy. That's my dad told
you. My Dad called. Your Dad told me that.
Yeah. When we went to south beach
together. Told me going to get laid here.
You calculate anywhere.
That's nice,
but I can't get laid to your father in
law. Yeah, that's good advice. Right?
Facebook.
Did you wish
you could sing like that? Absolutely.
I can. I do. You want to sing something
now you have another song? Oh my Africa.
I have to get it up. I have to pull it up.
You don't have it. I'll pull it up
right now. Um, hold on. Alright.
You know what I was going to say about
la though, at least our saving grace,
because there are a lot of good looking
people in Los Angeles. Yeah. Is that,
there's also a lot of really not
good looking normal people here.
So if you go to our beach,
like you'll see fat people,
you'll still see people that
like to eat and stuff. No, we're,
we're here and we're not going
anywhere. We're eating Sushi. Yeah.
Next to the imposters. Okay. Ready? Yeah.
So now we had some issue last
week with the toto song Africa.
We wanted to come up with
alternate lyrics. Yeah.
This is submitted by how do
they come with the hurricane?
How did it come about that? Cause our bid
day is called a toto. Oh, that's right.
And then we talked about,
you know,
how great it is and we were singing and
then basically the day songs. Right,
right. Yeah. And I did. I
didn't tell us on the air,
but I actually used to give a girl from
high school ride home every day whose
dad was in the band. Toto move. You
left that out? I forgot about it.
And then she and I found each other on
the Instagram because of the show or no?
No, totally random. Okay. Ready? Now
this is a submission from Taylor cane.
We can't play the music under it,
so I'm just going to sing it. Yeah.
Well you got voice my Gospel. Okay.
Ready? Yeah. Wait, can you do,
can you leave me in with the Braxton's?
I'd like to practice a little bit. Okay.
I just wanted to figure out who I am
today and kind of find my voice and
then I'll go into it a little bit. Okay.
Let me see.
You got it.
Uh,
I can only do the loss divorce yet.
Ah,
AH,
uh,
I don't know.
Oh Man.
Yeah,
it's gonna take a practice for me.
That's the original song then.
Those aren't the lyrics. All do.
No.
Okay.
Ready?
Please.
So, which fraction are you before
you do this? I'm feeling Tamar. Wow.
Cause I feel like I got my life and
I feel like I'm ready to get my life.
How about you?
Just shared is nice.
So I feel like the Tony.
Oh, okay. You don't,
I feel like I'm a superstar
of the family of the day.
You are Tony. Okay. Ready? I'm
just going to do the chorus.
This is submitted by Taylor cane,
so thank you Taylor. Thanks Taylor.
Can't play the whole song. I'm
here. It goes. Ready? [inaudible]
it used to take to
clean away all the pain.
There was nothing.
Not a hundred
but now I'm up.
A day has come and
the washlet gives me time
to do the things we never,
Heh.
Ooh,
I like it.
Really like that. Yeah. Okay. Yeah,
so it wasn't in this one that it
goes as I brown. I cry out in the
right.
Liz Longing for its soothing spread.
I know that. I must do
what's ride. Sure Bro.
Chrysler so fat.
My main mommy is non-binary.
There we go. That's really good. Now you
can't do it perfect. It's not perfect.
I got a practice that's really well done.
Thank you.
So I want to play this for you.
Yeah, I think you'll really enjoy,
um, these clips. Are you ready?
Yup.
Oh my God. If you would like a free
sample with no strings attached,
you can test drive the sports model.
I'm willing to consider any kind
of strictly friendly sports.
You can decide how strictly or how
friendly I want to. Tough chick.
Who's not afraid of guys?
If you get urges to beat a man,
I might get yours to let you win.
If you're willing to practice strictly
friendlies Fords until you achieve
perfection.
The fucking Tom for a challenge.
What the fuck is he talking about?
What does it look what he's talking about?
Why don't you describe
this guy to our list?
He looks a little like a skinny Lemmy.
And what's he wearing?
He looks a little GGL Anish
just on black tennis shoes.
Tennis shoes with white socks and just
some black black like biker shorts.
And he's got on some really
cool sunglasses. Right?
And he's got the Lemmy from Motorhead.
Creepy. Uh, like Fu Manchu. Yeah,
it's on. And he's got a paddle in his
hand and he's got fingerless gloves,
which is always a sign of sanity. If
you're wearing fingerless gloves. Yeah.
You've got your life together.
Everything is going well. Exactly. Yes.
I agree.
I was thinking about wrestling and
spank you, Frisbee out the public park,
you and your friends can they have a stone
rope and contest if you're willing to
make and use the left.
So one layer,
Susan Haag ties me the fastest wins.
I like a lot about this
guy. First of all. Yeah,
I do like that he is putting out there
what he's into and just he just going to
take right. What do we know
when he gets back? He'll have
his choices. No, no, no, no,
no, no, no. This is, this is
his version of swipe left and
right. Right. Cause I, I'm,
I'm all good. Thank you.
Um, and he also is, is uh,
you know, gear wise
he's on top of it. Yeah.
There's a very specific audience that
this appeals to and he's going to find it.
He's going to find it. It
sounds like there's a lot of
codes, code, wording that I,
I'm not really understanding.
Like this guy needs a high population
city by the way. Yeah, they are. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. South La.
What code words are you,
are you struggling with like Lasso?
How I understand that's what it feels
like. There's some code in there.
It's implied that um, we're not,
we're not going after cattle, right.
One after me. Right. So he's um,
he has his own version of sports,
right? Yeah. Right. Oh boy.
You got that paddle too and saying,
oh boy,
I might be inclined to let
dad was under this stuff.
This is probably someone's dad for
sure. I hope it's someone's dad. Who's,
who's listening to this show right
now. They're like, where did they hit?
You can have a bring your own belt party
belt blindfold me.
Then take turns with in me nothing.
And I'll decide which
woman has the best skills.
Maybe it's the cadence that's an alarm.
It's annoying and he knows
so much what he wants.
And I know these aren't the
fantasy was like, you know what,
I've always wanted a woman know what me,
he's done this hundreds of times and uh,
he just can't get that adrenaline
rush anymore so he's just like,
I'm putting it out there man. It's opt
in. Opt in up. Yes. Yeah, you're right.
This is a very specific, this guy.
No requests. I want you to last.
Oh me and we're nine inch heels
and leather and yeah. Yeah.
Grass. I like my is you
can make a special request.
You can practice self assertion with me.
What do you like to tough enough
when you're a sissy, check it.
This is why I don't understand.
You definitely need self
assertion encouragement.
I'm sorry you're still undecided.
There's more hands after this.
Now let's get to tell you
what's self concerns.
Oh Man.
There's definitely some dead
animals in his house and I will say,
I will say, yeah, I like
his background choice.
I like his audio. There was no birds
chirping. Yeah, he is a good mic.
It was a clean video. So he had some
help with production as I mentioned.
I think he has a clean diet. I mean that's
not a bad body. He's definitely fit. No.
Yup.
Would you,
would you think a date with him would
be absolutely terrifying for me? Yes.
A self assertion? Is that what you're
talking about? Self insertion? No,
the fuck you're a sissy
check or a shot chick.
You definitely need self assertion
encouragement. So it's like dom stuff.
Okay. Now let's get tell you. Oh Man,
this guy's guys
big time. Yeah. Huh? I guess,
um, when BDSM people go, well,
why don't we get a bad rep? Well, I
would say because of the time right here,
I think Tom is the type of
guy that gives you a bad rap.
He won't respect your
pronouns. Oh Man. Oh Man.
But he would love for you to whip him and
stuff. Yeah. Yeah. You know, I, again,
I see myself, I could do that,
but I don't, I don't know.
I don't need it to be sexual
for somebody else. Right.
It's just an anger thing for me. Maybe.
I don't know. But what if he's just like,
yeah, but I get off on it. So I
liked that part and I want them to,
Tj's on me or anything he's
not going to do is on you.
He do it on the floor or something.
That part creeps me out. Why
Tom came all this way.
Okay.
He can't just crank one out in the carpet.
It's a very,
it's a very specific world to inhabit.
You got to know a lot of lingo. There's
a lot of, a lot of stuff you have to buy.
Yeah,
it's too much.
Hi, nick hoc here and the star of
shuttle times hit series Gigolos.
I've spent my lifetime learning
about women, how their bodies work,
what pleases them and what teases them.
I want to introduce you to my Nick Hawk
genuine cast. Build a with movable balls.
Yeah, that's me. Eight inches. Heidi,
you say that sentence like it's okay.
This is hand finished and
colored for exact in detail.
You can even see the veins and insertable
Shafter. This baby is six inches.
It's one and three quarter
inches in diameter.
It's made up of [inaudible] free PBC
as squeezable moveable lifelike ball.
They have an 11 and a
quarter inch circumference.
The bill will also has
its 30 Suction Cup base.
By the way. Every time I
see, well he's about to,
as they go up inside of you to episode
where the guy was saying women want
smaller balls. It's a good, maybe
he's right. He's right. These guys,
they know women. That's one
thing. These guys know women.
Every time I see him or
his name in our copy,
Nick Hodge in my brain, it goes
a j hawk. I was like, wait,
we're about to see AGRX dildo.
Did you imagine age ain't doing this?
No Way. It would be the best if
he did a parody of this, so hey,
I'm going to do it hard. Cincinnati
Bangles in the off season,
I've crafted a dildo
after my own payments.
Do you guys want my cock and
movable balls inside of you?
I'm tired of hitting player.
I'm done hidden, hidden,
running backs with everything.
I got ready to stuff you big white cock.
Hey
looking like it was all of my cock.
We can you, can you just play the
beginning again when he's like
my shift in my boob.
Hi Nick Hoc here and the star of
shuttle times hit series Gigolos.
Hi. Hey Jay Hawk here. A
bangle, former green bay packer.
I spent my lifetime learning about women,
how their bodies work,
what pleases them and what teases them.
Huh?
I put my life playing football training,
hard hitting players,
Megan toggles and helping my team win.
I want to introduce you to my nick hock
and genuine cast building with movable
balls.
Want to introduce you to my,
hey Jay hawk.
Super hard cock dildo and movable balls.
Movable blocks. That's me. That's
me. Unbelievably unrealistic.
This is and finish and
colored for exact in detail.
You can even see the veins insertable
Shafter this baby is six inches.
This goes to guys,
I'm not very enticed. I got say, this
is not how you sell it to the women.
I mean there's some like super super
fans watch the show that are like,
let's just face it,
not attractive that are like,
wait a minute, aren't
you nailing him? Like,
my name's Barbara.
I bought a bar bar Bar Bar,
and so she, she buys it, but it's
mostly dudes who are like, ah. Yeah,
it's mostly dudes that are putting
this up there. Bumps absolutely
straight was one of the three
quarter inches in diameter.
It's made of PVC as quizbowl,
moveable lifelike balls. Oh,
I have an 11 and quarter
inch circumference.
The build will also has a
sturdy suction cup base.
Think of the endless
possibilities. The shower. Cool.
Now you can have your
very own sexy Gigolo.
Not a good sales for a fun
party or a little midnight.
Someone's not, I mean real alive
right here. How about this?
And there's a imagine the possibilities
of Jesus is a suction cup.
Imagine the possibilities. I mean, you
can even say it a little more excitedly.
You know, imagine the possibilities
and the Jacuzzi, your pool.
Well, dead behind the eyes with the
ad and come on. This is your Dick.
You're talking about
action.
Remember to always use a good lube and
clean your toilet soap and water or a toy
cleaner.
The genuine cast deal though with
movable balls can be found in the nic hoc
Gigolo collection from
California exotic novelties
with a movable balls. We think he
got for something like that. $10,000.
I don't think it's that
much. No, no, no, no.
I think it's like an internet
commercial. That's why. Yeah. Yeah.
They will give you a hundred bucks and um,
we got some free weights.
You don't have to pay me a lot more
just to say that introduction sentence.
I may not. This is my nine
inch dildo with movable balls.
Oh,
toms is a girl with a big one for me.
I would love to villagers be, this
is my light switch model. Yeah.
We'll movable type four inches too much.
I got the mold for you and it's
just flat out and it lays on that.
Imagine the possibility you can
use it to rest things on papers.
Uh, cause your baby teething. Use
the Thompson. You're a Dick Model.
Are you gonna buy me? I'm
nick a Jay hawks. If you
want it a little balls. Nick,
don't say
it's definitely nick. Uh,
do you want, do you want it?
No, I'll get it for you. Wears braces.
Did the other guys have one? No,
I don't think so. Oh, by that one? No,
I'm strictly friendly. I want you to,
I want you to, to meet that Guy
Tom, the guy with the paddle.
Yes. Yes. I want you to send
him a message. Would you? Yeah,
it's so it's a, I think it's always
interesting to me that people are so,
so sexual. Like they, they, they're,
they're comfortable making
videos at the world. Can See.
Is that just me being uptight
genes about just about life,
that I don't make videos about stuff
that I, I like if like if I were single,
I don't think I can make videos
like that and be like, hey guys,
who's into spanking? Or
No, no, but you have to,
I guess if you're into
something this specific, right.
Is that why he's doing it?
Because it's not like you can just go to
like a regular bar and meet people that
are in this crap. Yeah.
Yeah. That makes sense.
Of course. Um, by the way, so
last week we played this, uh,
the pathwell guy. Yeah. And he was, um,
he was,
we were trying to translate it.
It's probably the worst
version we've ever done. We've,
we didn't come close to getting any of it,
you know. Well, I mean we couldn't, uh,
we couldn't understand anything.
Yeah, it's tough one. Yeah. I mean
for John Wilson.
So
now you only have to be able to gain
weight.
I prepared these
and is English too. That's the crazy
part. It's yeah. Yeah. But yeah,
it's um, it's pretty crazy. Heather. A
translated it for us. Oh cool. What is,
what is he saying? So she says
to my mommy's I'm Heather,
uh, Janine from Twitter,
the girl that occasionally tweets like
my tweets making me feel like I got the
highest and tightest jeans in
the universe. First thing's
first, Chris Jeans, uh,
is the main mom and water champ.
No doubt about it.
Tom, your great, but the lies must stop
your Yorkie sipping lanes
like her already. Well,
we're never accepting emails again
and now it's top of the line.
Know now about the machete man.
He is a Jamaican and I'm assuming that
people are recording him because his
directions are horrible.
I had to call my actual mom who's from
Trinidad to help them with the ending of
this translation.
She was crying from laughter at Youtube.
And if you find any more videos like
this one or the Trinidadian, um,
from last year, we will be happy to
help. This is what we deciphered,
guiding the car says, just tell me
one time again. Machete man says,
yeah,
you have to go back.
So in past the station and go
over the bridge and go back.
So go down union, he passed. So, but he
goes, he passed so past, sorry. Right.
Soap, go down, union, keep
following the road straight.
Go across the bridge and go down
and keep going. Straight. Go on.
Don't bother to turn. And then the
guy in the car says, just go straight.
Just past the, uh, the back,
the Balaclava, not sure.
Balaklava station,
that's what I said.
And go over the bridge and go
straight and you're going to go down,
you're going to pass something,
uh, and you're going to go further.
So that's basically what's going on here.
Tell the one demo,
go
suboxone
candies.
Classic Bridge.
Don't,
nobody does go over
Monday.
I just want to heat up and go,
Shit.
Fuck Outta here. Go Stalk you.
Your Ego. You. Yeah.
Yeah. That guy's a male.
Live in the same world. Isn't that
crazy? Yeah, it's the same language,
but the different parts in
there. That's so wild. That's so,
I still feel like that's a crazy one
myself for like the Irish people are you
reminds me a little year, right? Yeah.
I was thinking the same thing. You know,
kind of built the same way.
Like I'm real muscular too.
Um, oh, fit. Uh, here's another
email. Let's see. Watergate,
2016 theory. Hey Mom, a couple
weeks ago, Tom Aka the water champ,
wrong drop the bomb regarding
his Jewish ancestry.
It makes so much sense. Ever since
wandering the desert for 40 years,
the Jews had been a very thirsty people.
No one or Tom drink so much fucking water.
Most of the countries dealing with this
heat doe right now and we should all
follow your lead and drink shit. Loads of
water. You're an inspiration. Keep it up.
Shalom, Oakley and Shalom to
you Oakley. That's very true.
Mm
hmm.
You're such an imposter. Um, okay,
so there's a,
I guess we should,
by the way, when I did the
ice house this weekend, um,
people were shouting that I was
the water champion. Okay. Whatever.
I got so much more than you.
By the way,
the spark let's machine was
out this morning since about
9:00 AM and then we sat
down to record at ou
noon and you were like,
can you bring me some water?
And I was like,
the spark let's machine's been
empty for hours. No, no you didn't.
No you didn't because you haven't been
hydrating since 9:00 AM three hours have
gone by without you taking a sip of water.
That's not true. I was, listen,
I was in the shower gulping down,
shower water is disgusting phone
ring and it was La DWP and they said,
we're cutting off your water
supply because you drink so much.
You're lying. No, I'm not. How
come you lie? Just so you know,
I'm drinking backup water.
Mark Chrysler.
I had drinking backup water that I just
had here for the last week and until the
sparkle Bark Chrysler. Okay. Christ. So
real quick update on that.
First of all,
huge thanks to everybody,
uh,
sending in, um, or buying a dispatcher.
Really appreciate it. Thank
you so much for that. Um,
I haven't released the tally because
I wanted to do it with Bertrand.
I thought that'd be a fun way to do
it. Um, well, well we can, we can,
we can end the,
the mystery.
It is not a battle as a blue
band said it is a massacre.
So wow. Uh, I can't give out the stats,
but this shit is no
longer time. Yeah. Yeah.
But I feel we all knew that in our hearts.
Of course we knew it to Burt is
the fat one. Of course. Of course.
So that's a real quick thing.
Also, aside from Bertrand,
thank you to everybody
that got a double pipe,
classic shirts turn restocked.
Uh,
it's a beautiful shirt and it's a special
thing to celebrate with people in your
life when you Bourbon Fart at
the same time, the DPC. Um,
bye.
Can I tell you guys,
I had a meeting with some executives
and a network and they're like,
tell me about your mom's house.
And I was like a Nice Lady and some Nice
Gentlemen, Gentlemen, Gentlemen. And um,
and I was like, well,
you know, it's like say
like,
but I told a room full of executives
about the Cincinnati Fart and about bird.
It's fat. It's less than a month away.
The number for the way. August 20. Yeah.
What is the 20th? The 20th?
It comes out. Yeah. Anyway,
I just thought that you'd like to
know that in your phones. August 20th,
2016 the year anniversary
of the Cincinnati far. Yeah.
Yeah. It was pretty fun.
Yeah. Describing it. You're
telling executive executive,
they're laughing, but no,
they loved it. But it was like,
I can't believe I got to do that.
How many times in your life do you get
to share a ridiculous story like that at
a business meeting?
Did you lead in with
a yeah,
here's some, uh, some bird updates.
Well, Joey fucked up to the
gills already understand me.
Just how you open the emails about why
is broke fat and all that shit. Listen,
you fucking knock it off with that shit.
Who gives a fuck?
Why is for it?
And Tom gives a fuck.
Who gives a fuck by the things?
Don't worry about us being jet closing,
calling until that shit. Why is anybody
fucking fat? Cause I like the cock suck.
That's okay.
By the way, do you see
this haze around? Yeah,
like seven,
eight in the morning wakes up so
early he gets up at like five 45,
six eating gummy bears and
just smokes like power.
And this is before he had a baby, right?
Yeah. Always. Always been like this.
But then does he go to bed at a reasonable
hour? I think reasonable, but yeah,
but not, he's not a sleeper. He's one of
those people that can't sleep. Yeah, he's,
he's a maniac.
But this is the best,
somebody sent me this
on Twitter that Doug,
Stan hope was in Montana and you know,
he'll just do a show and he goes,
he goes everywhere.
Doug goes everywhere and he has fans
everywhere obviously. Um, so he does,
you know,
sometimes like crazy bars and is obviously
like a post show hang or Doug's just
hanging out and smoking, having
a beer. And um, let's see.
Dot repairs going to be now I slur
your fucking fat work crushers,
not harm cigarettes.
Wait, it gets better. Do you
have the whole thing? Um, I,
I broke it up into three clips.
Okay. How Larry is, it gets better.
Oh, this is billings. Montana.
They don't understand how we know,
we know what Quirk Chrysler
here say your name right?
What's the other guys? Hey,
what's the other guy's name?
What's the other guy's
name? Tom. White Glue.
And sugary.
You put an unnecessary LZN
because Japanese people
can't pronounce the fucking
L's and the R's. So you put a
man, some guys it does it matter.
Oh Wow. I've done billings. Montana. Yeah.
Oh yeah. On a triple, triple run. Yeah.
No, I've never done it. Yeah.
I was trying to apply some of Saturday
that either of them here in billings,
Montana.
I can't find anyone fatter then Bert
Kreischer or Tom Segura argument is moot.
Oh, you didn't get the end. You're
the worst. Where, Oh, where are you?
He says bread is fine. Yeah. Yeah. We got
to get rid of blue. Bam. Damn it. Oh, he,
so he says Burns they tab. No, and
then this guy leans in and he goes,
Burt Chrysler's man,
it's the best. Oh Man.
Fucking blue band band
ruins collecting seeds
for Chrysler's fat. So it was
Doug Stan hope weighed in on wow.
Celebrity weigh ins now.
Who gives a fuck?
Joey Diaz. Yeah. This is
really taking America by storm.
It is.
It's really something we don't have any
international Burdis fat submissions
doing. If you're an international,
if you're in Africa,
if you're in the Netherlands,
if you are in, uh,
eastern Europe somewhere Asia.
And,
and give me like an international
bird is fat. Oh, that'd be good. Yeah.
You
so we have a,
I like an Asian bird is fat.
Like someone in Japan doing say it
and yeah, but like Chrysler is bad,
but you mean just not with an accent,
you know what I'm saying?
Or do you want them to be like
she was household Christ's love.
That's what I want. Yes, totally.
Do it in your language is gone.
Yeah. That bird is Moy Gorda.
Yeah. Okay. Bad crisis that tango to
it. Yeah, that's what I want. Yeah.
Yeah.
International
[inaudible] fine. Yeah,
we got to do that. That's true.
Um, here we go. Submit. Here we go.
Get the things going.
Here we go.
Oh, we'll sorry this you're blessed
snack main off saying you know, you too.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm trying to folks saying that they had
been handed vitamin water g forehead to
Ben had bagel bites to the homie.
Judas
had he been had money. I got some
mail. None of y'all have a, hey,
I been hashed next.
This dude is going to go, uh, he's
on a snack counting tear. Oh, okay.
He's saying that like a lot of
people who've had a lot of shit,
but he's had snacks. Okay. All
right. Should I respect, um,
and here's his snack.
Good shot photo for the girl at the jet.
Bravo. Would they boyfriend goes, hey,
I got the bugles nausea. Nacho cheese.
That's what the mask is. Nausea.
And when I got the traditional,
the traditional, you know,
father playing Caucasians.
I love it. Who's right?
No saying sweet and salty. You know what
I'm saying? Less fit. If you want a dad,
they're good for you. The
barbecue, you know that's for us.
You know we love barbecue
baby loss and stuff.
That's a lot of, you know what I'm
saying? Everyone loves barbecue color.
Let's get a tally going.
No say no. Say No. You know and then
you know no saying no what I'm saying.
No say no. No. I'm saying no. I'm saying
no what I'm saying. No, I'm saying no.
I'm saying shout out to everybody. I
don't know what I'm saying. No saying
I love it. I give a shout out. It's a
crazy load clue and that was awesome.
Shout to everybody during that thing.
Stop like that. There's got to checks.
Mix Shirt on. Yeah. This
guy loves the snacks. Dude.
That's a tight shirt. I know.
I kinda like him a lot. I'm
ready to get a checks. Make sure
that's all great. I would rock that shirt.
All right. The shit out of that shirt.
Should I wear my Rad dad shirt to my
meeting I'm about to go to, or no, Lees.
I am so jealous of your red dead shirt.
I got it. I'm sure there's bad day.
I know you got it from target, you said?
Yeah. How come there's no cool mom.
There are a cool mom should
know and not like that.
You know that fart loading shirt,
those? Yeah. I saw one that said,
wait a second and it said alcohol loading.
That's like,
I'm a fucking booze back.
Yeah. I like the fire one.
I know. I want a cool mom shirt,
man. You didn't hook me up.
I didn't see any of Mama shirts, but
I'm sure they have them. Okay. Yeah,
I just didn't see. I like
that. I'll get you a cool mom.
Sure do love me some checklist.
You know what I liked though?
There's always one shitty
piece and the checks mixed.
You know what I'm talking about? Yeah.
Oh yeah. Yeah. There's always a shit.
I don't like the Pretzel piece. I like
the the waffle thing. Yeah. You know?
Why don't they just make it all the
pieces I like, uh, they can do that.
And you've got to write him an email
and say, will you do a Christina?
I hate the circle pretzels. Yeah. You know
what I, you know what's that one that,
that makes your breath smell
like shit, I see that. The onion,
the guard delis or whatever,
you know, check me out. Fuck,
I love those. But then there's like one
shitty piece in there. It's like the,
the, the one with sesame seeds on it.
The big one. I fucking hate that one.
But I like those brown left. You know
the brown pieces, the hard crackers.
The best piece, right? Yeah. They just do
all hard crackles, flavors in that one.
All the flavor. That's
right. Not alone here. Um,
Mary, right. We've got to get going. What
do you want to, but you got something,
maybe talk about the, uh, the August
1st, the poachers coming out. Oh,
the poster. Yeah. I mean,
we have, uh, for, well,
for Patrion people at a certain level,
20,
$20 level is it being shipped to them?
But,
um, for a everybody else, you can
still get it. It'll be on the site.
It's a commemorative
Cincinnati fart poster.
I'm so excited for this.
It's really spectacular.
Uh, we'll have it up on the
site within I guess five hours,
five days or so. Within a week
or so. Yeah, within a week.
But if you sign up on page
on.com/mom before August 1st,
you'll get it for the Patriot on price.
Okay, cool. Um, and there, by the way, um,
all the Patriot fulfillments
have been going really well.
Everything that we've put up there,
we've said we were going to do it.
We've done including bonus
content. Um, and there's, uh,
there's a new bonus episode
coming out on the first. Yup.
A whole bunch of stuff coming out
on the first. Yeah. So patrion dot.
That shit down.
patrion.com/mom put that down.
Um, the posters really, really
cool. The artwork is amaze on that.
Yeah. Geez. I can't wait for that to
come out. All right. I think that's it.
Anything else? That's a jeans.
Uh, your mom's house, podcast.com.
Tom Cigarette ICOM thousand ranch.com.
Thank you guys.
patrion.com/mom for listening and,
uh, we hope to see you at a show.
Thank you for listening to our show and
we'll, we'll do it again next week. Bye.
Miami's yeah, I mean, right.
They really listen to this.
Hey, listen up. This is Gerald the
original mummy. I'm in charge here.
I want you to listen to me. Oh, you
niggers need to go to your mom's.
Go both got.com and it's cool,
but some of the new God shut.
You need a new boss there. The
rental though, that Gucci Shit Dog.
You know what I'm saying?
Go to this.
I click on this towards support
Tomi antenna. I got kids to fit.
Keep it in hundred. He's, God.